I keep this in the stash you know man
like remember we're all Beyonce says she
keep the house also huh yeah I'm oh yeah
I'm rocking with you
Beyonce I'm gonna aim type of tone in my
back pocket
pull it up
what up G Q this is young inmate and
these are my essentials all right one of
the first items definitely a white tee
when I can't function without no fresh
whitey all that designer stuff is cool
sigh to have you know that just be
firing them and dead but I'm gonna take
person when I wake up I could throw in a
white tea for the day and be cool
I can't wear no dingy white tee and I
mean somebody sees me while show them
they still got the underarm stings under
maybe the old Cooley staying somewhere
or a Hennessy stain always a fresh pack
I mean always got to get a fresh pack of
white tees you know if I can count how
many turns up with a pack o eighties or
halfway T's oh and I could got my dollar
for each one definitely be a millionaire
it's just part of me man fresh team and
it's like winning drugs my favourite
chicken I could take when I'm going to
throw some time to me and got him they
got every other brand every other arts
every other flavor and I think everybody
like these are some because nine times
out of ten I'm barely father so when I
do get out of it like at least two guys
the chips taste like a like chicken
strip everything in one like just nice
and seasoned like me you hungry you need
these trip these chips you are like
saddest father and a lot of people don't
know neither the technique to these
because when you get them you don't just
get them and open them up and you got to
turn upside down if it's only season in
the spicy stuff is in the bottom
[Music]
okay let's see if we got a good we got a
couple good ones there
now I mean they gotta be looking like
this and they gotta be seasoned see it's
like one or two in hair that's part in
that to season like this one this one is
a little chilly compared to this one but
yeah he's my favorite I can't eat it
right now for that come on grizzle I
can't beat you once though because
they've got 300 minutes of sodium minute
so I try not to do it too much but
whenever I get the taste for me is like
my go-to and roll grab bag of chips
speaking of grills this is definitely
one item I can't I can't go outside
without like I don't my dad's just cool
I mean nice or tomorrow buzz down pretty
much I can leave this at home my chain
beautiful this is my logo on medallion
my trophy loved it beautiful but I can
leave this at home these right here I
can't leave these hand over there like
no matter like if I leave the house and
I don't have my grills like I literally
spin the block and go back to get my
girls before that's like the worst thing
for me is to not have my girls my mom go
out publicly I just feel like this part
of me is my signature I had grilled
since like 2013 I was like six years ago
I got my first pair of girls and I'll
have bottoms actually at first all this
for gold bottoms that's all I had
that's how I started and then eventually
as time came on I wanted more so I got
six and then six turned into tops top
was turned into diamonds and then
diamonds turned into eight now eight
tops
ain't bottoms fully bunched up and
that's
today my favorite my favorite jury I
can't live without I got 4 pair right
now I got two two pairs of gold ones
that I had for a minute now that got
like actually diamonds in them as well
and then I got to floodwaters two-parent
flutterwings both eight bottles eight
tops how many pairs are lost
man I don't lost it good mmm
Oh ten pair groups so like you do the
math man it's a lot of money involved
definitely learned my lesson my issue
was putting the girls when I first got
it was putting the girls into a napkin
when I take them out I put it up put in
my pocket forget about it
what's this in my pocket garbage throw
it out let me see one yet so I
definitely learnt that lesson I never
put my grills in the tissue that's one
thing that anybody need to know if you
got grills don't never put your girls on
the tissue you will always end up
throwing it up that girl dealer cologne
man can't go nowhere without smelling
good
petty [ __ ] for example a lot of people
know me in the video
I pulled the deed or out in my back
pocket and I said I'll deal with Mike
alone she said my sin is her obsession
but yet it survives smells great the
ladies love it real clean real pure and
it sticks and I can't I can't leave the
house without it I got a smoker that I
actually bring it with me most of the
time like I will bring my own type of
people out for a high flame awesome I
smell good is fading I have to spray
these three more sprays real quick it's
like a little traditional thing like a
dish the Cologne des
[Laughter]
it's like my pimp cut man a lot of
people know too because was a train that
thing back in like the early 2000s and
to me is like it's like one of my most
lively things I mean I drink out of a
regular cup but like for some reason it
tastes different than this cup and as
you can see I got my logo on it
let's go change and this is like a brand
new as well as like just a cup to have
whatever you want anything no he's got
to be anything I want water juice but at
the same time it's like when I bring it
places it's like my little my little
trophy it's like I'm showing off the
brand at the same time and then I can
have my little sit whenever I feel like
it and I like that is black black I feel
like there's a don't color rag kind of
makes you look like a party and flag
black is a little more classy little
more cool I got this cup from from
Barney's and I just slapped my logo I
was like oh I can't I feel like I said
like I'm addicted to spicy food I love
spice if it ain't hot it ain't right
and I gotta be spicy like I don't like
the mouth hot sauce I need it hot and I
eat it for fun pause in a good way
I'll put a hot sauce on of course
chicken seafood my shrimp my fish my
odors and noodles I put on everything
then there are fruit I don't pass those
on fruit my collard greens anything that
I feel like deserves hot sauce is
household and that's me
my headphones man I need my headphones
because like first of all I like the
block a lot of things out I like to be
in my own zone definite when it come to
music so my headphones is like a go-to
thing I can't get on the plane without
headphones I can't move
Airport without headphones sometimes
when I'm sitting in the car and I don't
want to hear what's on the radio or
something on a Surrey I'll put my
headphones on I'll need my headphones at
all time definitely young and me she's
one of my favorite artists it's always
got her a plan and then and I listen to
a lot of old school stuff in the
headphones I like soul music R&B music
for some reason it sets the tone we
listen to it in the headphones in life
makes you feel like you got a space real
quick
rap is cool I like to play rap throw out
laughs awesome speakers and stuff like
that I listen to beats a lot of times
are comes on I'm more when I listen to
beats on my headphones Oh
more so than hearing a loud kind of
noise me here every part of the
instrument and then the beat sometimes I
write with nobody I cappella I just
probably have something on my mind and
I'll write but majority out of time I do
listen to it be first just to get a
sense of where I'm gonna go with the
lyrics and yeah my hat messed up but on
yes my New York Yankee everybody know
you made for win it this is like my
go-to hat I have so many hats I probably
got like probably hello over thousand
everybody if you know that you see me
that mostly it's like my signature had a
flag it's a Brooklyn thing to you know
Brooklyn was always known for that that
low flame you know jay-z he set the tone
with that and it's like my go-to hat I
wear this I grab this I can wear this
with anything that's lay the blue one
since today I got on the rarity but I
usually arrived and they review that's
the traditional going gang keys
I saw them two type of person I don't
really uh carry cash
I'm a colored person you know me and I
got healthy cars chunky parts you know
man he ain't just your average cards and
I'm not really I don't really like to
carry a lot of cash I'm not one of those
rappers that walk around with a bunch of
racks on every now and then if I know
I'm about to go out and shop I'll
probably have a significant amount of
cash but most of the time like I just
carry my cars when we play like a good
$200 the most of our pocket but I'm just
one of them I'm just not that type of
person I just feel like that's a walking
target they have a bunch of money in
your pocket
I just number them I start my car
another situation anything happened call
it up
fix's send me another one easygoing you
know once you lose money you lose one
snow getting that back so you definitely
can't go no way around my car swipe
swipe yo what up G Q this is young MA
thank you for checking out my essentials